christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know i again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
but can you can you indulge me in
indulge me for once just we're running
out of time indulge me for a minute i
understand you see it as all these
things but you surely recognize that the
world sees you as white you know the
world reads you as white and if you were
to ask me some things i like about being
black i could talk about cultural norms
i could talk about tradition i could
talk about the kind of commonalities i
feel around the diaspora if i were to
ask you what particularly if you're
saying whiteness is a thing that is
being constructed as negative and
shouldn't be
name something positive that you like
about being white people are attacking
mark lamont hill for asking this
question but it's a brilliant question
not because it stumps chris ruffo
actually the fact that chris ruffo can't
answer the question
is the same reason why mark lamont hill
did answer the question and it's just a
fact of our culture now you are not
allowed to say that there is anything
good
about being white